are there any nice parts of North Korea
there are more than 2 000 private
resorts for the Kim Jong-un in this
Resorts they're all
pleasure Squad living young girls in
North Korea the officials have to find
the youngers who look pretty and then
when they turned a 16 or 17 they send
them to capture Pyongyang and train them
to become their three groups in pleasure
to have a satisfactory group is where
you perform in sex acts the other group
is a happiness groups where you learn
how to massage the dictator or like give
him the in acupuncture like that and the
last group is a dancer that Musicians
music
musicians yeah I thought he liked magic
he does like he likes the girls like
naked and dancing more than that yeah
yeah most guys like the naked girls more
for magic I really prefer David Blinn
yeah yeah yeah you like magic over okay
okay let's be friends yeah